when you reach our age you use the
telephone we don't make anything at home
right now the only thing we make is in
the toilet that's it
[Music]
on our way to try some trendy foods this
is Bobby hi Nance Adele
hi do you guys know what kind of what a
trendy food is plentiful for me is
challenge I love my area chicken noodle
soup and some brisket that's trendy food
for me do you know that people put
trendy foods on Instagram you eat it you
eat it on inside basically that's how
they like me what they're gonna happen
[Music]
the hall called egg waffles been around
since like the 1960s
it's actually really popular in China
talent so me and my friends got a ticket
thought was really cool we can use it in
shape things like ice cream cones so
it's just kind of how it got started
sometimes we have lines out the door
just like people waiting hours together
I guess you want to get me fat fat low
fat far from it I haven't had a waffle
maybe in 23 years 23 years I'm high just
the taste your waffle you have to be
very honest I'm absolutely I'm a very
honest person that's how my mom and dad
raised us honestly cats and gets you
everywhere I can't wait I don't wait I'm
anxiously waiting right so let's get
going let's get up and the dog I'm so
excited this is absolutely gorgeous
my teeth this egg room is beautiful - a
beautiful day but I feel my deed enough
you don't why I'm walking away from
what's wrong with you I just don't like
you am i speaking regular I have a
chocolate waffle that looks absolutely
scrumptious I have a chocolate lover ice
cream why is it cold lover why not plain
chocolate is it special everything in
here is chocolate sprinkles
I have M&Ms and I can't wait to eat it
after step can I chop into it okay well
I have a Nutella and vanilla Oh on
original waffle now I chose Nutella and
vanilla thinking you tell it makes you
thinner why don't we think that because
I think people that are on a diet
always go for Natalia
but I'll let you know guys if I get
thinner or if I gain a pound from eating
this one what it's looking with Oreo
cookies that are diet probably in my
mind a little almond sprinkled on it
what do you got I have a green tea
waffle with black raspberry ice cream
sprinkles mochi whipped cream pokey when
you bite into the waffle this definitely
is the people who love chocolate I can't
wait to bite into these why - I've never
had a straight reliable no you have an
old geyser like this I hope the wish
comes true - sensational I'm diggin it
as I'm making it to you I'm having
another try a waffle hmm
dunno why it's funny eating a waffle
this way the only way I could describe
this really nice telling you this is
[ __ ] tool oh my god really [ __ ]
delicious and I'm telling you again
[ __ ] delicious
I told you on the 9th one my sister
doesn't curse IG has orgasms when she
eats do you guys think that edglu is
grandma proved graham are pros she was
really want them to be nuts in a trendy
restaurant you really want to be
reporting for my granddaughter was alive
14 years ago and approached me I
probably would have said that's an honor
I had to come in here not annoy do